When he was two years old, he ran off and they found him sleeping in the barn...
...between two giant hooves of a Percheron stallion.
She said that horse was protecting him and nobody could convince her otherwise.
I read this article about what you do for people with horse problems.
The truth is I help horses with people problems.
We expecting company?
Mr. Booker?
Yeah.
I want you to take a look at my horse.
I don't know if I can do anything,...
...but I'm prepared to give it a go if you'll help.
Do you have a problem with that?
Isn't it like obvious?
Not to me.
When I work with a horse, I like to know its history.
If I'm gonna figure out what's going on in his head,...
...it'd sure help me if I knew exactly what happened that night.
Are you afraid of anything, Tom Booker?
Just make yourself comfortable.
I am comfortable.
Well, in that case, you can bring in the pasta.
You missed a button.
Thank you.
The Horse Whisperer.